[موسيقى]
في منطقه نوفو اسبريسك وسط روسيا بدات
قوات الصواريخ الاستراتيجيات تدريبات
واسعه يشارك فيها اكثر من ثلاثه الاف
عسكري وحوالي 300 قطعه من المركبات
والمعدات في محاوله جديده على ما يبدو من
موسكو لاظهار قوتها النوويه تقول وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان هذه الخطوه تجري وفق
خطه الاعداد والتدريب لهذا العام حيث
ستقوم قوات الصواريخ الاستراتيجيه بتنفيذ
مجموعه من الاجراءات للتمويه والتصدي
لوسائل الاستطلاع الجوي الحديثه بالتعاون
مع تشكيلات عسكريه اخرى والقوات الجويه
كما سيتم الى اهتمام خاص لاستخدام
المسيرات من طرازات متعدده لكن الجزء
الاهم من التدريبات سيكون حتما ذلك
المتعلق باستخدام انظمه صواريخ يارس
النوويه البالستيه العابره للقارات اذ
ستجري انظمه يارس المتنقله مناورات في
ثلاث مناطق روسيه خلال تلك التدريبات لكن
دون ان تحددها وزاره الدفاع لكن ما هي
ابرز مواصفات صواريخ يارس التي تعد العمود
الفقري لقوات الصواريخ الاستراتيجيه
الروسيه يمكن ان يصل مدى الصاروخ الذي
يعمل بالوقود الصلب الى 12 الف كيلو متر
وهو قادر على حمل عده رؤوس حربيه نوويه
صاروخ ياريس يمكن اطلاقه من منصه مخبئه
تحت الارض او من منصه متنقله ويحتاجون نحو
سبع دقائق لكي يكون جاهزا للاطلاق يبلغ
طول الصاروخ 22 مترا وقطره متران ويصل
وزنه عند الاطلاق حوالي 49 طنا ويمكن ان
تصل سرعته الى 14 ضعف سرعه الصوت
[موسيقى]